[Music]
[Music]
if we could start perhaps by you saying
who you are
and then i think you've got a muscle my
name is christine felsen and
we are here to talk about primitives
my name is mary lyon i'm the chair of
the association for children damaged by
hormone pregnancy tests
he just took these tablets out of his
door and said take these
in terms of both defense obviously i
have no hands
i only have four toes on each foot
they whisked her away from me put her in
an incubator
she died four days later
[Music]
they seem to be in denial of what is
blindingly obvious to any
observer who is listening and watching
it's a life sentence the effectively
struck
is multi-generational it just goes on
and on and on
humans aren't guinea pigs they're not
lab rats
the fact that he did this study for five
years is in itself
damning enough it takes a huge toll
on people to carry on campaigning when
when every time you
raise your voice you seem to be knocking
your head against a brick wall
it was worth it just to face them
let them see face to face who it is
that's actually coming after them
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
bit height known me
i'm on my own
i've never met anybody
married had children
it's almost no i'm not there
if i'm with someone someone else
they won't look at me and talk to me i
think she has a person
with me you must want to scream at
people
oh yeah yeah you feel like you're
talking yourself because
they just didn't bother to they're not
bothered to listen
so nikki was one of the first people i
met when i started investigating this
drug
but i met numerous people with all sorts
of different malformations
some of them visible some of them heart
defects or brain damage
and the manufacturer always denied that
primitives caused any of these
malformations
but i think that this is one of the
biggest scandals in the pharmaceutical
industry
and it's been covered up
[Music]
obviously the the major issue that i
have
the um my right arm only goes down to as
far as the wrist would be
and my left arm i have an elbow and
that's
it
[Music]
i've also only got four toes on each
foot
one foot is considerably larger than the
other foot
i've had a lot of dental procedures
because my
jaws don't fit together properly and
my teeth are still rather difficulty
i've had eye surgery as well i
see predominantly out of one eye
[Music]
probably my earliest memory of noticing
that everybody didn't have a brother
like stephen
was probably when i was in primary
school
a couple of friends were going to come
home for dinner and i seemed to remember
them screaming
and crying in the car so frightened of
him
but they were only children who'd never
been around anybody with
this kind of disability before but i do
seem to remember thinking to myself well
what's the matter with them that's their
problem and dad
because i promised you didn't
steven's 52 years old he's my older
brother
he has uncontrollable epilepsy with
learning difficulties
so he's 24-hour care
[Music]
he has to be fed wash dressed
he doesn't sleep at night he's seizures
he has seizures every day
[Music]
my parents have always been really keen
to give him as normal a life as possible
[Music]
he's flown on planes he's driven through
europe in the car
he even came skiing with us once that's
good
there's nothing more powerful than a
fight for justice when you've
experienced so much suffering
yeah there are families that have
suffered their whole life
a lot of them and that does give you
some fight
and we have the truth on our side and i
have to trust that that will come out
because they can't hide from it forever
[Music]
i've never known anybody so determined
so tenacious
[Applause]
there really is no stopping her
we have been campaigning since 1978.
those tablets were given to pregnant
women
and they contained 40 times
the amount of an oral contraceptive
we have been fighting for bayer to admit
their culpability
and we continue today
thank you very much
they feel they are such a huge
cooperation that nobody can touch them
and it was important to let them know
that nobody's too huge if there's an
injustice
somehow or other justice will be served
might take us 50 odd years
but we'll get there in the end and
really the message was we are not going
away
we are not going away
hormone pregnancy tests came on the
market in 1958 in europe
and they were manufactured from
synthetic sex hormones
like the contraceptive pill but stronger
the market leader
was shearing and they sold it under
different brand names
so for example in germany it was called
deuganon
and in the uk it was called primidos
[Music]
in the 1960s the toe test is still the
dominant test for pregnancy
a lab technician would inject the toad
with urine come back the next morning
see if there were eggs at the bottom of
the jar and if there were that was a
positive test result
primados is initially a treatment for
amenorrhea
delayed menstruation and secondarily
becomes
used as a test for pregnancy
these marketing campaigns really
aggressively target the toe test as
more expensive slower not as sensitive
so you have to wait
a couple weeks after the first missed
period before you can do it
so there's all these advantages that the
primitives test has allegedly over
the toe test
[Music]
a woman will go to her gps she'll say i
think i'm pregnant
g people say here take these two tablets
um if she bleed
then you're not pregnant if nothing
happens then you are pregnant
that time period four to eight weeks is
when the embryo is forming
it's it's when the brain is forming the
nervous system
the arms the legs the internal organs
after the eighth week um the embryo is
fully formed and it just grows
but that those first eight weeks is
where it's all happening so you're
taking a
man-made synthetic sex hormones high
doses of it
um would i be surprised if it caused
problems
as an embryologist no i wouldn't all
right
[Music]
looking baby his feet were very blue and
when he was born and then said he's
probably cold or something
i had been a father before but i
immediately became concerned that i felt
there was something
just wasn't clicking right with his
child shall we give it to his her
in the end i said look i'm not happy
about this we need to get somebody to
look at him
he was put under the care of another
senior consultant pediatrician
and then came the bombshell um those
those words
i'm afraid this is serious i said well
you know what's the problem he said well
he has a condition called tricuspid
atresia
which means that part of his heart and
one of his vowels
are not there
first of all i perhaps should say that
when alison became
pregnant she went to her gp he took
these two tablets out of the drawer and
said well we don't have to do a urine
test it's it's easy these days
you just take these two pills take one
tonight one tomorrow night
i remember questioning this at the time
i said why is he giving you
why's he giving you drugs to test for
pregnancy and she said well you know
doctor says it's fine and this is the
new way and this is progress and
you know
[Music]
we kept thinking that i was pregnant and
kept going round to the doctors
he said are you trying for a baby
[Music]
so that's when he gave me the two
tablets
and said you take one when you get home
another one in the morning and then come
back and see me and then we'll go from
[Music]
there
i was actually delighted because
i had assumed it would be an examination
or a urine test and the fact now that
this new way of finding out you were
pregnant was out
i just thought it was brilliant when
permados comes on the market very few
people ask any questions about it
the patient trusts the doctor the doctor
seems to trust the manufacturer
and the uk regulator doesn't seem to
have much oversight
which is surprising considering this is
all occurring around the time
of the biggest pharmaceutical scandal in
history which also affects
babies in the womb
kevin dunnellon is 11 years old and
lives with his family in a suburb of
liverpool
in the first few weeks of her pregnancy
his mother agnes don ellen
took five sleeping tablets the tablets
were called distaval
they contain the drug thalidomide
i think what most people don't realize
that cinema
is the worst peacetime disaster
in terms of death and damage to
people since the second world war
it's quite amazing that so many mistakes
have been made
since the dynamite disaster happened the
lessons weren't really learnt
when my waters broke first
i wasn't obviously in labour um
and soon as nikki head came
through that's all i remember she was
late
you know she was overdue so it was
decided to
induce which which they did and
when she was born i remember the first
thing because they took her away
very very quickly i came to at one time
and there was a priest
at the end of the bed and i thought
to be honest i thought i had died and i
was in heaven
and what they wanted was the name what
we wanted to call her because they were
going to baptize her
because obviously i didn't think she was
going to survive
i did kind of think oh gosh they're
taking a long time
the nurse came in and they were holding
sarah but they dropped it quite tightly
and she just said look i'm really sorry
i i'm gonna have to tell you that your
baby was born
without the lower part of her arm being
formed
i don't think anybody actually said she
had gone
but that's what i was led but every time
i thought
came to i kept coming to and going off
again
and he said no she's alive and she's got
birthmarks
and she handed it to me and i said
started to kind of check she said
oh and i just said i want to look at her
properly and i just undid
all the wrapping and what it was it was
just like a tiny little
um like a bud if you like
with these five tiny little digits at
the end of
her elbow and obviously where the hand
and the arm hadn't developed was just in
case in this little
piece i don't think they really knew
how to handle everything
because you don't think of the long-term
implications
all you can or i was concerned about was
she was healthy she was safe she was
gorgeous
she was mine and i loved her and that
was it
so she was special
you know i'm sorry that's okay
[Music]
the first real alarm bell is sounded in
1967
and it comes from a bit of an outsider a
remarkable woman a pediatrician called
dr isabelle gao
my mother was born in a small town
in the southern part of hungary my
mother
both her sisters and her mother were
taken to auschwitz
and they were all survivors of that
absolutely extraordinary that they
survived but they did
it was because my aunt was already here
married to an englishman
that they came to england as opposed to
australia or canada which i think were
the other
main places for these refugees to go
[Music]
she was working in carl shelton queen
mary's hospital
with women who had had malformed babies
she was looking at the possible causes
the really crucial turning point in the
history of primados
is this paper published by isabel gal in
the prestigious
science journal nature and she notices
that a few of the mothers
have taken primados or amerone forte
during pregnancy
she was incredibly perceptive about
people's symptoms time and again when
she interviewed
the mothers of malformed babies the same
sort of things kept coming up again
looking at the hormone pregnancy test
was an accidental discovery as a result
of her being
very perceptive and making links in the
interviews that she had with these
mothers about their medical history
the same time she writes a letter to
william inman who's head of the
committee for safety on drugs at the
time
one of the key figures in the early days
of regulating new drugs
in the united kingdom was professor bill
inman
bill was a delightful man he had
suffered polio
as a child despite that went to medical
school and graduated as a doctor
my choice of career was really dictated
by the fact that i had polio as a
medical student
yes but of course being wheelchair-bound
made it impossible for him
to carry on the kinds of jobs that
doctors would be expected to do
so he chose to do what was in effect
a desk job if you like and he joined
the regulatory authority so once
isabelle girl publishes her research in
nature in 1967 she's worried about it
and she contacts the regulator professor
william
he's kind of receptive at first but then
you know you look at the correspondence
and i notice on
the heads of paper it's always men
involved in this and there is this kind
of paternalistic
patronizing tone to the correspondence i
think
and there's this almost suggestion that
this young woman
couldn't possibly have spotted something
significant
that everyone else had missed it's clear
that
inman was having difficulty coming to
terms with isabel gal's forceful
representation of the data and was
himself rather reluctant
to damn a drug without what he
considered to be strong evidence
so even though he's dismissive of isabel
gal's findings he does decide to set up
his own study
and that involves going to the national
register finding babies that have been
born with malformations
going to their doctors finding out what
drugs their mothers have taken
and then having a control group as well
and he says in the correspondence
this is going to take some considerable
time and you have to ask yourself at
that point
the ethics of keeping this drug on the
market while you're effectively testing
to see
whether women who take the drug have
malformed babies they're
they're being used as guinea pigs
in 1975 professor inman finally
publishes the interim results of his
study in the british medical journal
[Music]
and it shows that fetal abnormalities
have been recorded
among those women using hormonal
pregnancy tests such as primitives
and it concludes there is little
justification for their continued use
[Music]
now the committee on safety of medicines
issues a leaflet
saying that it is possible that the use
of these preparations
could lead to abnormalities in the fetus
enough to warrant a label being attached
to the box
warning primitives must not be taken
unless it's certain
that the patient is not pregnant
that was such a shock because they had
declared
from day one that there was absolutely
no link whatsoever
with with any kind of adverse effect and
taking the hormone pregnancy tests
[Music]
and then in 1977 a decade after dr gal
first made contact with him
inman publishes the full outcome of his
research
and that leads to a warning being sent
to doctors
that an association has been confirmed
between the drug and malformations in
babies
you'd think wouldn't you at this point
some people might hold their hands up
and say we've made a big mistake but
that doesn't happen
it's up to the families to start
investigating to find out what's been
going on behind closed doors
we had no internet we had no email
everything was done
at a much slower pace so there was only
one way to
to contact people and that was through
the mail or by telephone
um but it it it all it all
came very quickly and and an
awful lot of people came forward
[Music]
susan stern collects her daughter
vanessa from kranich hospital near
knottsford in cheshire
for the past three years the hospital
has been vanessa's home
nobody knows what the doctor's giving
them
you take tablets because the doctor says
you should take them
do you know the brand name of the tablet
that you actually took yes
what is it
there are still large large numbers of
doctors relatively speaking prescribing
drugs which are
actually dangerous and for which there
is no justification at all
most of the children that we have on our
books at the moment are affected with
heart conditions
invariably very serious massive
malformations of the heart
hair lip and cleft palate limb reduction
in much the same
way that third amount of children were
affected the mp jack ashley has four
times asked for a public inquiry
and four times been turned down he now
plans to take the issue further
today i should be approaching the
ombudsman and asking him to find out
why there was this excessive delay of
eight years
before any official warnings were issued
by the government
or by the csm we have a watchdog
committee in this country
the committee on the safety of medicines
and it is their job
to satisfy the public that drugs coming
onto the market
are safe i can assure you that we will
pursue this
all the way
so in 1978 there's been all this adverse
publicity and the regulator's saying the
association is confirmed
the manufacturer shearing decides
they're going to pull it from the market
for what they say are commercial reasons
but behind the scenes within the company
it's clear
that there has been a lot of disquiet
and concern about this drug
i was invited to go to germany by a
group of people working within the
german health service
i no sooner arrived in my hotel i get a
telephone call
and this guy said i'm not going to give
you my name he said but
i work for shearings and i'd like to
meet you
i want to tell you something
[Music]
he said i'm a doctor and i work in the
laboratories
[Music]
i just want you to know i absolutely
support what you were doing because i
know from my
work that this drug just terrible things
to rats
i said why all this cloak and dagger
stuff he said well he said if they find
out i've spoken to you he said
we have a court we have a court in the
company and he said i will be tried
i will be out and i will never get
another job
in the 1970s i was a private detective
operating an agency
in brighton
i received a phone call from a solicitor
he invited me to go up to his office to
meet a senior executive with
a pharmaceutical company called sharing
he was based in the uk office
and his primary responsibility was the
salem marketing of
various pharmaceutical products but
including the drug known as
primados he said to me
the drug itself potentially had a risk
of damaging
the unborn fetus and he felt he had to
leak it
i knew there were a set of documents
around which were supposed to be quite
damning
good evening tonight we're going to
examine a vitally important issue
we discovered that they were in the
hands of a private detective in brighton
it concerns the way we make sure that
drugs and medicines in regular use are
safe
so we invited him up for lunch and sat
and talked to him about the whole
the whole story and asked him would he
give us the papers in a report prepared
by greg dyke
we're going to look in detail at the
history of these drugs to our surprise
he gave them to us and didn't want
anything for them we're going to explain
how they worked
why they were introduced and what
happened in the years after it was first
suggested
that they might be damaging to the
unborn child this is a letter from
sharing chemicals in sussex to the
headquarters in germany
in 68 and it says ethically speaking
we are not satisfied that sufficient has
been done to remove the suspicion
which has been cast upon primitives to
sufficient degree
for us to be confident in supporting its
continued availability
now that if you take away
the motherflower words what that
basically says is we're not sure this
drug has been properly tested
so you think about it there's a warning
on the packet saying don't take it
if you're pregnant there's the regulator
saying the association has been
confirmed the drug companies taking it
off the market the family think they've
got a pretty good case
so they decide to see the company
cheering had a meeting which was held at
leeds castle
to make a decision about how they were
going to deal with this
were they going to settle or were they
going to fight it
they made the decision that they would
fight it
they have two things to prove one is
negligence and one is causation
we didn't think there would be any
problem with with proving
negligence however the big issue was
did the drug cause these injuries or
didn't that's causation
that is hugely difficult to prove
you have to rely totally on historical
information evidence and the opinion
of expert witnesses
they are relying on the industry to have
done the research they might have got a
few people to do some studies and
they're lucky
they've got isabelle gal this
conscientious woman who's come up with a
study and spotted
a problem but the only people other than
her who seem to followed it up
is the regulator and they don't seem too
keen to help the families
because they're the ones that left it on
the market for eight years
because we were legal aided we had
limited resources
we had about 10 or 11 experts who were
willing
to give evidence that they had
personally
completed studies that actually proved
the link
we felt that we had a good case
two of those suddenly decided that they
couldn't appear
one by one these expert witnesses who
were going to
speak on our behalf suddenly turn around
and said i'm sorry but
um i'll have to withdraw you know
i've been offered a research grant which
would cause a conflict of interest
we ended up i think with something like
708
and shearings had 31 experts
[Music]
we were outnumbered outgunned absolutely
we didn't have the finances
and we just had to disband
[Music]
judge bingham who's presiding over this
case in war courts of justice
says look there's not enough evidence
we're going to have to put this
case on pause but there is a concession
i do give the plaintiffs the right
to come back to court
should new evidence
which supports their case come to light
at the time i just felt that was nowhere
else to go and and there were two
options you could either become quite
bitter
or you could get on with your life and i
decided just to get on with life
one of his teachers at the special
school he said to me one day
sean's getting worse isn't he i mean by
this stage
i mean sean was 10 years old but i had
to carry him
to the car he couldn't we couldn't walk
to the car came to the car
and then he suddenly said i can't see
and then he
collapsed backwards
the terrible thing that is his younger
sister was sitting next to him and i had
to say to her
you know hold sean don't let him fall
over you know
[Music]
nobody who's not lost a child can
understand
they can they can be sympathetic uh and
say
how absolutely dreadful but they do not
know
they have no way of knowing how awful
how absolutely awful it is
and you you have to really will yourself
to to keep going uh because it's it's
just
some absolute devastation you know
[Music]
after the court case collapses in 1982
nothing happens it goes quiet
nobody talks about primitives for 30
years
[Music]
but one significant thing happens over
that time period
the children who survived grow up
and they start asking questions
[Music]
yeah okay um just say your full name for
me carl
yes carl murphy um just tell me about
growing up what was it like
i was born with a obviously fingers
missing on my right hand
small digits on me left i also have a
cleft valley and a hair lip
i've got no toes on me left foots
it was hard when did you start to think
that it might be primidos that caused
your problems
i got a computer in 2007
and i started putting it in i
contacted my mum at the time and she
said there was
information in the attic i found
documents
that had shearings headed paper sky news
has obtained documents which suggest
that a drug
once used as a pregnancy test may have
caused deformities in babies
i contacted sky news i told them the
story
in the 1970s and 80s parents tried to
prove that the drug primidos
affected the development of their babies
in the womb they give me
jason farrell's email address and cell
phone number
thirty years on the children allegedly
affected by the drug
are attempting to rekindle their parents
legal challenge
uh he turned up and we i brought all the
stuff all the information
i had and we went through it
carl has now made an extraordinary
discovery
that may reignite the case right so this
is a german magazine and
that's you that's me that's me yeah the
german journalists who wrote this
article gave carl's mum
confidential papers that they'd obtained
from shearing
after sitting unread in her loft for 30
years
copies of these documents are now with
lawyers in london
and form the backbone for a potential
new
legal challenge
well i'm sifting through all these
documents and i can see there's
internal correspondence from the company
there's the isabelle gal study but
there's another study that they're
referring to by the royal college gps
and that seems to have found a higher
incidence of malformations
still births infant deaths and
miscarriages
by women who took this drug and the
report author says the drug should be
removed
from the market so i'm thinking this is
a big story
inside this suitcase there's a huge
story here
and i can see that carl's looking at the
same documents and for him this is a
smoking gun
this might explain why he is the way he
is
so he decides he's got the case
for legal action
[Music]
i contacted a drug manufacturer they
just swapped from shearing to bayer
and he said they did not hold any
information regarding
primitos i got the association
up and running we had a lawyer
i had to go down to london to the legal
aid departments
to meet them and present it in front of
the panel
and then we had to wait
hello excellent thank you so much thank
you thank you peter bye bye now
bye bye it's all official
to be told on the steps of lime street
station
where jason you've been granted the
legal aid of 25 000
was like amazing we're one
further step forward here
i did don't get me wrong i i stalked the
ice storm
they would get emails off me day night
morning
i really did i was asking for freedom of
information requests
constantly they
used to hold a 10k run down in newbury
so i entered myself and other people
entered as well
[Music]
i'd also talk documents down there
which i had told sky news i was going to
present
to the pr of herbert
[Music]
[Music]
so that's the way they want it fine
[Music]
[Music]
sort carl decides to use his legal aid
money
to invest in research at newcastle
university to look at the available
scientific evidence and see if it can
show a causal association
between the drug and birth defects and
we know
from the case back in 1982 that there
isn't much available evidence
so sure enough it comes back and it
shows that this association
can't be shown and for carl who's pumped
his heart and soul
into this campaign this is a huge blow
[Music]
i thought here we go two steps back now
you know how can we you know where's
this going to go
how do we carry on
i walked away i walked away because i i
had to think of my own mental health
i i could feel myself just ready to
me had to just explode and
i had to just say enough's enough
[Music]
i actually became chair in 2012
there's so much that people are not
aware of
[Music]
there are so many things that are hidden
that need to be exposed
we're not the the people being looked
after
we're the people that are being
tolerated
that's the frightening thing for me that
we're not actually human beings with
statistics
and that's really what spurs me on
because i
see the human side of this every time i
meet with our members
some have never had children because
they couldn't bear to go through the
same
kind of experience
some are still changing nappies for you
know children in the 50s
it's made me stronger in that i don't
accept anymore
that we can't do something about it we
can do something about it
everybody i know that today we will have
new members
this woman from wigan brings tremendous
energy to the campaign she's also quite
savvy so she gets the families to write
to their local mps with their stories
and they have a huge impact the work
that she did getting
the mps involved getting the
constituents writing to their mps
she is just absolutely phenomenal
she brought knowledge she brought
dedication
she brought expertise she bought
sympathy
and she's such a good human being
and she did it all on a voluntary basis
and finally in 2016 she is successful in
pressuring the government in setting up
an expert working group that will look
into primitives
and there in the terms of reference
asking if there is a possible
association
between the drug and birth defects
this group is overseen by the medicines
and healthcare products regulator the
mhra which is the modern day equivalent
of the body that professor william inman
wrote
[Music]
i was delighted absolutely delighted
this was supposed to be an independent
group of scientists who would look at
all the evidence
every single piece of evidence
i was invited as a an expert
to make sure that this was a more
balanced inquiry
and a more open inquiry and a fairer
inquiry
than perhaps would have happened in the
past
[Music]
when it was announced that there was
going to be an expert working group
looking into the question of whether or
not
the hormone pregnancy tests that cause
fetal malformations i was very surprised
i thought
surely surely we know this this was
demonstrated years ago
while mario's been busy with the
association lobbying parliament i've
been going through these documents that
carl had in his attic
[Applause]
and there's a lot to go out they
i realized i needed a bit of help so i
drafted in
a producer called liz lane
we have to gather as much evidence as
possible from lots of different sources
there are studies from around the world
there are correspondence between people
you don't know who they are
it's like a huge jigsaw puzzle and you
have to start trying to piece it
together
while we're going around doing our own
research and
following up leads it's not just us
there are more victims joining the
association and they're doing their own
research
and i got contacted by this woman from
bolton
i was born with i had a lot of
obstruction
at birth my stomach's on the wrong side
i have seven spleens spinal defects
and all in the arts
i've had a lot of operations to try and
correct
um the stomach you can't be you can't
put people back together
i've had about 20 major operations
she'd been to the national archives in
london which for her is a 400 mile
round trip and she said i've got these
documents to show you
and they've been confidential for 30
years so
i agreed to meet up and we have a chat
in her kitchen
they've covered so many things up so
many times so many victims have already
passed
so many parents they're not gonna
they buried the children and they don't
they don't they've not even seen the
evidence
they've not been able to explain
i just think it's appalling they're
never gonna
they're never gonna see it so there are
all these files relating to criminals
spread out on the kitchen table
but amongst them there's this one letter
by professor
william inman after he's just met dr
isabel gal and he's talking to his
colleagues
about it and it's really striking well
this is an extraordinary letter from the
senior medical officer for the
government to his colleagues in 1975
where he says he's just had an
exhausting meeting as he describes it
with dr isabel gao
and goes on to say she believes she
should have had more funding
for research and that a large number of
babies
may have been born with abnormalities
during the eight years that have elapsed
he goes on to say that we're defenseless
in the matter of the eight year delay
this is hugely significant it's a
crystal clear
admission from inman that he got it
wrong that from the time
that israel gal came to him flagging up
her concerns
to the warning appearing on the packet
that women may have given birth to
babies
with malformations unnecessarily
and you would think therefore that he
would apologize to her
but it's quite the opposite isabel gal
is an intelligent dedicated
but rather sad little person and
finishes i dealt with her
sympathetically to the best of my
ability but do not believe
that we've heard the last of this matter
the saddest thing for isabel gal she was
an absolutely
brilliant scientist and doctor
and her career finished at that point
she never
was allowed to have another senior
position one of the positions that she
had been offered was withdrawn
and literally she never had the
opportunity
to complete the research she she felt
was so badly needed
i think it's absolutely shocking
absolutely appalling
i saw the effect that it had on her
her personal life and her professional
life
why wouldn't you do something about it
why would you obstruct why would you as
a medical authority
obstruct um the fact that harm was being
done
smothering that by also
silencing the person that had
found the connection
so then we get another breakthrough and
it's
relating to around the same time as the
british families are taking their legal
action
in 1982 there is a german prosecutor
who asks shearing to hand over all of
their documents relating to perimeters
and hormone pregnancy tests
to see whether there is a criminal
action against the company
now for various reasons that doesn't go
forward but then what he does when he's
finished with the documents
is he puts them in the national archives
so we put in a public interest access
request
and the archives come back and say yup
you can come and have a look
so now we're going to get to see the
inner workings of the company
and what the papers reveal is the state
of panic that has gripped the company
by the legal action being taken by the
british families over criminals
some of the most interesting things that
start to jump out at us
are minutes of meetings that shearing
had with the british lawyer that they
had hired to defend them in the run-up
to the court case in 1982.
and one of the first things he says to
them is have you done any tests
when did you test this drug before you
put it on the market
and what becomes clear is that whilst
they have done some tests in 1969
that's years after this has been given
to thousands of pregnant women
so in the minutes of this meeting
there's this extraordinary revelation
because it says it was apparent that no
toxicology had been carried out before
introduction
either in germany or in the uk
nothing shocks me anymore i feel that we
were duped
i think the doctors were certainly not
given the information that they needed
and it's the fact that our regulators
have allowed an untested drug to be
given to a pregnant woman
immediately after the thalidomide
disaster so i just find it's
unconscionable
[Music]
all the while we're digging through
these documents
and then we find something that is
perhaps the biggest
revelation thus far in the investigation
it concerns details about the study
professor inman
had been conducting using the medical
records of women that had been taking
primitives you remember this is the
study he conducted
in secret while the pill was still on
the market about which the women
themselves
knew nothing and that study revealed
that those who took hormone pregnancy
tests had a relative
five to one risk of giving birth to a
child
with a malformation that's a high risk
that's above normal that's massively
above normal
this figure we've never seen before the
families haven't seen it when we tell
them about it
and neither is anyone involved in the
story so inman
passes this information onto the
manufacturer and he says
i'm taking this unofficial route to
contact you in order to let you know
that you need to prepare yourself
for potential medical legal challenges
now this is a british regulator his job
is to protect patients
it isn't to warn the manufacturer his
first instinct should be
there's a dangerous drug out there we
need to take it off the market but
that's not what his instinct is
his first instinct is to say to the
manufacturer
look out professor inman meets a sharing
representative and tells him that he's
not happy about the way that his study
that showed that there was a link
between primados and birth defects has
been received
[Music]
so he says to the scientists that he has
destroyed
all the evidence on which his
investigation is based
and he has done that to prevent
individual claims
being based on his material
so he burns it he destroys it
he gets rid of the evidence that could
have been used by the families
to sue the manufacturer
that's a cover-up
[Music]
i think that was reprehensible i think
he should at that point
have made his findings clear made his
findings public
you should really come clean and tell
the public what's going on
the documents were an absolute game
changer particularly
in relation to the documents we already
had there were
unbelievable and it actually gave me the
opportunity then to
find a really good solicitor who was
willing to take our case on
which we'd really struggle with before i
was actually astonished by the
size of the task that murray had taken
on
she had what i can only describe as
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
pages
so when we looked at the paperwork that
we've seen we realised there was
two defendants here bayer as the
manufacturers
that have taken over from sharing
and also the secretary of state for
health in their role as regulators
so then comes the next lead we always
knew that this drug had different brand
names in different countries
and we learned about this case back in
the late 70s
over this drug called just test that
seemed to use
similar hormones to perimeters
[Music]
there was really very little information
to go on at all because the details of
the case
had been sealed by the court part of the
settlement agreement was that no details
could be released including even the
name of the boy involved and his parents
but we did manage to find eventually one
piece of documentation that remained
and that did have boys and his parents
name on it
so liz gets this phone number and we
ring the number of this
woman in florida a woman answers and she
says she's ellen hicks
are you the mother of this little boy
and she says
yeah that's me
we have a really long conversation and
she's quite emotional
but she ends the call by saying yep
she'll help us she'll talk to us
even though part of the settlement
agreement was that no information about
this case
should ever be revealed
[Music]
there was a lot of chaos in the delivery
room and they
wheeled me out and took me into a
recovery room
then the doctor came in and explained
that our child had been born with
horrific
horrific birth defects and that they did
not expect him to live
robert and i laid him on the bed and
unwrapped him and looked at him
and it was just mind-boggling it was
horrific
the most apparent thing was he didn't
have any hands and feet
his limbs were deformed they
ended just below the knees on the legs
and
around the elbows on arms and then his
face was disfigured
other than that he was beautiful
[Music]
little blonde headed baby he looked he
looked like a little angel
and we started questioning this drug
that my doctor had been given to me
we were able to go through and
subpoena documents from squibb and
that's where we really started putting
the case together because we found
research documents that they had in
their files we found
internal memos that were
very disparaging of
the effects of this drug it came very
became very clear to us that this drug
was harmful
that they knew it was harmful that this
drug was never tested on a pregnant
woman
so halfway through the case lawyers
represent the manufacturer
throw the town in they say we're not
going to continue
we are going to pay out
we're not going to admit liability the
condition is
that this legal team cannot take on
other challenges from
other plaintiffs but crucially
there's a multi-million dollar payout to
justin
then i got the call that he had taken
his own life
the amount of hormones in this pill
just test that i was given the dosage
was so massive
that it should have caused a miscarriage
and in the writings
before he died he kept saying i should
have been a miscarriage i was never
meant to be
and i don't know why i had to live like
this
so he never got over it
[Music]
so we knew that this was a hormone
pregnancy test and that it used very
similar components to primitives but we
weren't
sure yet just how closely they were
connected
but luckily for us there was this guy
who was
a scientific researcher looking into the
history of pregnancy tests
and bayer who would never give
journalists access to their own internal
archives it actually allowed him in
and he got hold of these documents that
were
hugely significant this is sort of a
crucial
document an official sharing list of
products
in germany so these are the trade names
in germany these are the trade names in
auslan so in foreign countries and these
are the trade names
under license government simplex in
germany primados
and under license a guest test so
it seems fairly unambiguous squibb
essentially sold
a modified version of duogenon of
primados in the united states
under the trade name of guest test
you've got on one side of the atlantic a
family who have
suffered from a drug that is essentially
primitives marketed under a different
name
who've received a huge payout whilst
over here
the families have got nowhere with it
and received nothing
so we've had all these breakthroughs but
i also know about something else that's
going on
in aberdeen and it's a professor at the
university
who has been doing a study quietly into
fish and the embryos of fish if he gives
them
the components of primitives
i've called him over the years i mean it
literally was a number of years i called
him saying how are you getting on
and he was very very guarded in fact he
was even slightly annoyed that i had his
phone number because he didn't really
want to talk about his
research but then one day he calls me up
and says
okay i'll talk to you about what i've
found
we are interested in seeing what
primidos did
to embryos in my lab we work on a range
of
embryo systems one of the best ones
we've got is zebrafish
because they are they develop rapidly
very very quickly so you can see what
drugs do and you can
follow it live and see what's going on
they share 70
of their genome with humans so they're
very very similar and most of the
of the disease-causing genes that we see
in humans are also shared with zebrafish
high levels of high concentrations of
the
drug you get various damage
you see damage to the brain to the eyes
to the ears
to the fins to the spinal cord to the
yolk sac which is the equivalent of the
placenta if there's damage to the fin
you would ex you would suggest that that
might you might see limb damage in a
human
um if you see damage in the heart
obviously you might see damage in the
heart in a human so
the initial conclusions are that with
high doses of primitives
it's harmful to the fish it's causing
problems to the nervous system to the
vascular system and it
causes developmental anomaly
so we've gathered all this information
we've got it's research in aberdeen
we've got the case in america we've got
all these documents from the archives in
berlin and we decided to put together a
short
documentary film
[Music]
and we take it to the houses of
parliament to show to mps
along with some of the families who are
seeing a lot of this information
for the first time campaigners recently
petitioned number 10
and this led to an expert working group
being set up by the government to
examine primitives
we will not go away we will be coming
back
to the minister we will be coming back
to the government
and we will make sure that our
constituents
those families get the truth get the
information
and get the acknowledgement and help
that they
[Music]
the mps after seeing this are shocked
they're looking at this and
thinking it's an utter scandal they
hadn't realized the full extent of this
particularly the extent of the cover-up
that had been going on
and they're fired up now because there's
this expectation that's growing
for the expert working group that the
government's put together that is going
to come back
with their findings
you can't see the curse trimados was a
drug given to women in the 60s
and 70s i first learned about it six
years ago when i made contact with those
campaigning for the truth my sister said
you really gotta watch
this there's this chap who looks
incredibly similar to you
then the doctor came in and explained
that our child had been born with
horrific
horrific birth defects and that they did
not expect him to live
and it was just mind-boggling it was
incredibly painful to watch really
way before i was born there were warning
signs
that this type of treatment ought not to
be
available we started questioning this
drug that my doctor
the families have now by this stage
had a long history where the science
seems not to be taken seriously by the
regulator
we have got this this working group now
looking at
things i mean what do you hope happens
we are looking to see
finally whether the leopard will change
its spots frankly
will the regulator finally stand up and
do what it
has failed to do in 50 years or so
will it finally bring this to a
conclusion
and be more transparent in the way it's
operating there was absolutely no
reason to give a healthy woman a drug
to test to see if she's pregnant i think
the closer we get to publication
the more tense things become no that's
true
so that's yeah mari is clearly
starting to have some concerns about the
process of
the expert working group
and she's feeling a lot of pressure
because not only can she not talk to us
but
she can't let the families know what's
happening
because she's been gagged she's actually
had to sign something to say
she can't tell me she can't tell members
about what's going in the meeting
and it's only later when she actually
gets a lawyer to have a look at it
because she wants to
be able to let families and other people
know what's been going on that this
lawyer tells they know
actually it's really strict you could
actually be sent to prison if you were
to break this
some of the more damning evidence had
not been touched at all
none of the the german evidence had been
touched and i questioned that
very very quickly
very often her voice was not heard
although she tried very hard to be
involved in the inquiry
she was subjected to all sorts of
restrictions
[Music]
when i asked about my role within
the group which they'd said was as
observer only
and my challenge was if i'm observer
only
how can i contribute if evidence is not
being looked at
[Music]
all the reports were prepared by mhra
which is very questionable because we
were actually investigating failures by
the regulator
and yet the regulators themselves were
actually preparing all the work
for the committee to look at and these
reports i felt in some ways were quite
biased there was an unwillingness to
look at the
at the material in a very open way
in november 2017 after sitting for two
years
the expert working group is ready to
publish its findings
and the families are desperately waiting
to hear whether this group has found a
possible association between this drug
and malformations as set out in the
terms of reference
reagan used to be now relating to a
report released today on whether the use
of a hormone pregnancy test in the 60s
and 70s
was responsible for serious birth
defects
the conclusions they've made is actually
on a causal link
which i just cannot believe the terms of
reference are
absolutely specific that what they're
looking for or should be looking for
is a possible association did they say
whether they'd found a possible
association no they've not looked for it
i have no confidence that the
information they studied was 100
non-biased so i'm afraid i don't have
any confidence in the report at
all i feel let down all of us
they won't even allow me to come into
the meeting where they're going to be
publishing this report and i thought
you know what the hell i mean we i
should be there i should be listening
so i mean i was absolutely i was very
very angry
and upset at the same time
[Music]
i was in the back of the room at the
press conference
and the report authors were up on stage
and they make this big announcement and
it's not televised this conference they
don't allow cameras in the room but they
say
we have found that there is not a causal
association
between the drug and malformations
and i'm thinking well that wasn't in
your terms of reference
you were asked to look for the causal
association that's raising the bar they
haven't
found the causal link between
thalidomide and malformations in babies
they were asked to find if there was a
possible association and if so was that
properly acted on so i'm thinking you've
had two years to look at this
and you haven't actually answered the
question so all i wanted to know from
the chair of this group
is is there a possible link between
primitives
and malformations we were open-minded
whether there was any association or not
and then the the result of our um expert
group was not to find any causalization
essentially you're not willing to say
whether there's a possible association
or not well medicine
is always uncertainty and if any new
evidence was to arise we would certainly
be happy
to look at that from where we stand at
the moment based on our deliberations so
far we did not find a causal association
there were there were studies that were
included that were
non-peer-reviewed that were produced by
the manufacturer and
shearing in preparation for litigation
would they not be
biased that was all the relevant data
that we
that we have looked at as part of our
remit and of course that's the problem
we have there are so many biases
and these older studies the 1950s and 17
are not robust as we would
as scientists look at them now so it's
inconclusive
no we are we are confident that we have
not been able to show a causal
association we've not been able to show
it because you're saying that
everything's outdated and not robust
well this is the most extensive review
there has ever been of this this topic
it's thousands and thousands of pages
all our findings will be available for
for
public to view in due course we're very
open about all of that
the mrs lyon who's the chair of the
association was present at every meeting
and able to comment
so we are we're confident in our
findings that we have not been able to
show a causal association
just just finally are you confident okay
okay thank you thank you
further to that interview we were
provided with another statement
[Music]
oh
[Music]
it was that that day for me that this
didn't
just become about my family this became
something much wider for me
because i it was appalling it really was
appalling
you always ever drink when you come in
come on
first on the night of the publication of
the report
after that meeting and my dad was rushed
into hospital with heart failure
and my dad was the only one there
with his son who he cares for a
wheelchair by the bedside
i know i just thought
i have to get justice for them
i can't let this go and um
that's dad said to me how did it go i
was thinking
his blood pressure don't ask me that no
i'm i said not good dad but don't worry
about it now
and he said well i suppose i suppose
that's it then is it i said no
it's just started
if ever there was a report that reads as
if the conclusion was written first
and the data was made to fit then this
report ticks all the boxes
does he think it's appropriate that an
expert working group changes the goal
posts
halfway through a process they were
asked to look at
a possible association not a casual link
not a causal link but a possible
association
i'm afraid to say i smell something like
a very large rat in all of us
the women and families affected by
primitives are still suffering from
their loss
they are still grieving they will not
give
up they and all of us
deserve no less than the truth
i do not uh agree this is a whitewash
and let me just just say say one thing
at the request of the association of
children damaged by
hpt's mr speaker an invited expert
nick dobrik who is uh who the house and
the outside world will
know well as a respected and well-known
thalidomide campaigner
sat and attended all meetings of the
expert working group i do not think
the the notion that mr dubrick is some
sort of government yes man who
who would have allowed a whitewash to go
on stands up to much scrutiny if any at
all
this was a load of nonsense i didn't
recognize what they were saying i had
never
supported the conclusion of that report
they used me blatantly to try and
buttress their conclusion it was a lie
in the end the government spokesman
minister
apologized in the house of commons to a
question from
um mike pennant and i i thought it was
totally shameful
i was absolutely furious
i just knew i had to get this this study
reviewed i had to do it
i was told that carl hennigan was
someone
that actually looked at the meta
analysis
of studies he works on evidence-based
medicine
all i said to him was professor i need
to speak to you
and he just said you've got five minutes
she basically said
could you go away and look at this
expert working groups report
and in doing that could you give us the
honest answer
are they correct or is this something as
an independent person you could look at
and tell us what you think is going on
going through the whole report started
concerning
that actually it was in a direction of
travel that was not independent
there were things done for instance the
quality assessment wasn't one i
recognized
there were issues about how the results
were reported
i said carl this report is very strange
i don't understand it
we must get hold of the data and analyze
them ourselves and see what the real
answer is how easy was it get hold of
the data
well it wasn't either because at the end
of the day we had to detail it through
the house of lords to request this data
my lords the raw data which professor
hennigan needs to complete his review
has not been made available and my view
that this is tardy
and uncooperative on the part of that uh
body this is the point where i think the
system is broken to be honest
why in a position where we're supposed
to be doing an independent report
can't we access the data that you have
actually spent two years working on
and presented to the government just
does not make sense to me
after a further delay the data were sent
to us
we have statisticians epidemiologists
all look at the data
when you actually then started to look
at the more specific malformations like
congenital heart
disease the effect size went up to about
89
when you looked at neurological nervous
system malformations
even higher and then a specific syndrome
which is a combination of
four or five effects called vector even
greater effect
so the more specific the malformation
the more
the effect was greater and all of them
were significant
the conclusion that i reached from
our independent systematic review is
that there is clearly
an association between the use of
primitives
and the risk of fetal malformations
do you think there are people out there
who
as babies in the womb were malformed by
this drug
yes and i think the committee on safety
medicines knew that because they put it
in the warning
in 1975.
[Music]
this is a really significant report
because it's taken the same data that's
been looked at by the expert working
group and come to a completely
different conclusion on the side of the
campaigners
and this is all down to the fact that
mary lyon didn't give up
she went and got these independent
experts to look at this
and as soon as she gets it she takes it
to germany
she wants to go and meet the german mps
the members of parliament there
and explain to them what's going on
she also takes the fight to bayer
turning up at the annual general
shareholders meeting in bonn
massive meeting
[Music]
when i finally went to give the
presentation on on how we felt that
we've been treated
they cut the microphone so they would
not allow me to continue to speak
i was so frustrated that i actually
tried to go and speak to them directly
and she marches right up the front of
the stage
and confronts the managing director
mr bauman will you finally give justice
to the victims of primitives
i just wanted to say in that forum
that they did have information that they
were aware of the damage
and they had done absolutely nothing to
stop it is there a possibility that
you'd like to meet at another time
to discuss it they wouldn't engage and
eventually a security man came
and literally just pushed us away just
put put the hand towards our faces
no pictures okay okay i'm basically
we're virtually ejected then from the
the conference room
despite many of these families having
very little
to cling on to there is one thing that
is going on that is giving the campaign
some hope
and that is the scientific research
that's been carried out in scotland
you'll remember that professor vargasen
has been up in aberdeen looking at
zebrafish and discovering that
primitives is causing
malformations to embryos in the fish and
there's been pushback from the regulator
into his research saying that the doses
that he's using are too high
so he decides to go back and revisit the
study
so this this is some of our new data
using much much lower doses of
primitives and at first glance you don't
see much difference right
so this is the control this is the
untreated and this is the treated embryo
and there is subtle damage here so this
region here is the heart
and you can see here there's a raised
area of the heart
which shouldn't be there this is this is
basically um
where fluid is accumulating in the
forming heart we've got a brain
malformation where there's part of the
brain missing
which is missing from here and you can
also see changes in the part of the hind
brain
again um which is not apparent in the
treating also the eye you can see that
the eye that where the lens is starting
to form and invaginate you can see that
there's a
it's not as broad as it's not as wide as
it should be so this is a very low dose
which we think is physiologically
relevant and we are doing a lot more
testing at the moment just to double
check this and to get more numbers and
to do
um higher and lower doses as well as
other time points but we're confident
there's something going on here
it's important to remember that the
expert working group said that there
were
questions about the validity of outdated
studies and that's why some of the
evidence wasn't
as robust as they would like it to be
but now you have an up-to-date study
using the latest techniques finding that
this drug does cause damage
to the embryo and it starts to raise
more questions about the validity of
that report the report
that the manufacturers bayer are relying
on in their defense
the report that was supposed to draw a
line under all of this
there was something else that we
discovered about that report it was due
to be published a month
earlier than it actually was and we got
hold of
the original draft document and that
turned out to be
significantly different and this study
is all the lines represent the most
definitive reports on hormone pregnancy
tests and
these eight highlighted all show an
association
that was also taken out
so i decided to put in a freedom of
information request to try and get hold
of the correspondence
to find out who was behind these changes
and why they'd been made
and it took nine months and was even
blocked at the department of health
at minister level but eventually on
appeal the information commissioner's
office said
that it was in the public interest to
release the documents
what we were given was full of redacted
names but it was clear that people
outside of this supposedly independent
group
were influencing the conclusions in some
emails there are clear changes of text
to make an association between the drug
and malformation
seem less likely
and it appeared that a line saying it's
not possible to scientifically rule out
any association
was removed without all the members
being told
there's also a warning from one expert
that there was a blatant attempt
to rewrite the remit of the group
it's clear that there's been outside
influence
from the regulator on what was supposed
to be
an independent report and they've
changed the meaning
of the conclusion
[Music]
we contacted the regulator and they
confirmed that they and the chair of the
group had endorsed the changes
i think that liz's freedom of
information at request is
incredibly important it shows that key
changes were made
to the report and i haven't seen any
evidence to suggest that
those changes were endorsed by
the entire expert working group it looks
like they were made at the last minute
it gave a totally different meaning
to the report and it's something that as
lawyers we're looking at very very
carefully indeed because
that's a report that will be relied upon
by the defendants
there's a lot of uncertainty flying
around westminster i'm getting emails
from the department of health asking to
see our original documentary
i've got mps coming up to me saying i
need to speak to the prime minister
about this i know that she's having
meetings theresa may's talking
to some of the people within her own
party who are raising concerns
and you get the feeling that something's
going to happen and then suddenly
there's a massive turning point when i
looked at the report
i felt that it wasn't the slam-dunk
answer that people had
had said it was now i'm not a scientist
a lot of very eminent people had put
that report together
but those two references that suggested
that they'd come to a decision on
balance
and hadn't been able categorically to
rule out a link between
primados and congenital anomalies
suggested to me that maybe actually this
was something we should
look into
[Applause]
[Music]
that was on top of this wider issue
of women campaigning for many years
about this
um raising their voices and seemingly
not being heard
[Applause]
one almost felt it was sort of women
being patted on the head and said
they're there dear don't worry you know
you're imagining it or it's it's not you
don't know we know better than you do
the fact that they have produced
experiments that
prove that these drugs were dangerous
and yet they suppressed that evidence
if you feel that there's been a problem
that you have suffered but
nobody will hear your voice and it's you
know
great well done to the campaigners
but until she was actually well done
to uh to jason and sky for actually
having picked this up
and run alongside the campaigners and
help to give this publicity
[Music]
i explained to within my number 10 team
that i think that we should
look at this we should have a review on
this
ultimately if the prime minister decides
it should go ahead then it will go ahead
[Music]
that's called the independent medicines
and medical devices
review and that is chaired by baroness
cumberlage
are you making signs for me to speak up
right okay thank you now
baroness cumberland immediately set
about
meeting all the members please feel free
to tell us
what you want us to hear or if you've
got
issues that you think we might miss um
and about your family and the impact
that primados
it was all about the patients it was all
about the families
how could they interact
they listened they were empathetic
they didn't judge it it was just
incredible
but our overriding determination is to
ensure
that voices are heard
i think the
as i age that i i notice
the tiredness because i'm using two
arms all the time to do anything like
grip or twist
or pick up or whatever
and look
i am actually becoming quite wild
i would like to be a government
[Music]
[Music]
then
[Music]
you can't let these people suffer like
this and there's
hundreds of people like him few
thousands more coming forward all the
time you know you have to do
you can't just you can't just ignore
this
[Music]
all we want is the truth
[Music]
[Music]
so we're told we're going to get this
report by email and we decide we'll
be with mary we'll go and
receive this information together and we
get to
her home in wigan and she
is pretty down in the dumps because she
feels
that the soundings are
that this may not be good
why i just feel very depressed quite
honestly yeah
quite worried yeah she is feeling a huge
weight on her shoulders that if this
doesn't go the way she wants it to
she's going to have to break the news to
all the families
[Music]
i felt quite sick when i came to hope in
fact i really
struggled to open the first page oh my
goodness
i've conducted many reviews but i've
never encountered anything like this the
intensity of suffering
experienced by so many families and the
fact they've endured it for decades
oh god that sounds so promising
i see now there you see the system and
its leaders need to acknowledge what has
gone so badly wrong
that's more than expected
i'm trying to be very calm
and i can't it's a fact
it's been acknowledged at last
so much for putting makeup on that was a
waste
oh good grief
i know i need to read the rest but i'm
i'm quite stunned i am absolutely
stunned
there's a tissue as well
good grief
[Music]
hi nicky hi manny
right i just wanted to let you know
what has happened with the uh report
from the mmds
the results are good the results are
very cut
are you shocked i am yeah they've
acknowledged that harm was caused
it was avoidable it was unnecessary
um that the regulator did not act
in the best interests of our families
[Music]
my dad's not here
i think that's the baddest thing that
your dad won't know no
no no no no
no no no no
no not yeah that's not my bathroom yeah
the eureka moment for me was the fact
that they said from 1967
that primitive should have been taken
off the market that there were
regulatory failures
had the government regulator at that
time
um basically done the job that they were
paid to do
that drug would no longer have been
available there would have been warnings
given to
all the mothers from 1967 and i'm one
who was actually given that tablet
they would have been saved all this
heartache
it was amazing to read the report it was
amazing
and horrifying at the same time because
all the stuff that isabelle went through
and and did and never giving up
was there on paper now
it's not so much for her vindication but
for the victims of this because that was
always her driving force to get
recognition of what the victims have
gone through and are still going through
some of them but
and what they what they went through
without their knowledge
and without being informed about what
the consequences could have been
it was always her driving force so she
would be
one you know she would be delighted
[Music]
[Music]
because there'll be questions in
parliament as well or there's gonna be a
statement from the minister
do you what when's your next live next
slide is
at 10 o'clock 15 minutes
jason farrell is this a vindication for
you and much more importantly for the
victims of primados
yes it is we have been looking into this
since 2011 for the victims
they've been looking at it since 1978
since the evidence
first started to emerge in fact the
evidence had already emerged amongst the
medical community
back in 1967 and this review today says
that this drug should have come off the
market back then
[Music]
how do you feel about the fact that it
is the patients
who've had to bring this to light i
think it's a scandal
i think it's an appalling thing i think
it is
our showing rarely that the healthcare
as a system
doesn't work
it's taken families decades to get to
this do you agree with baroness
cumbridge that this is a scandal
yes and i was gobsmacked because this
was the first time
that anyone in government had actually
accepted
this is a scandal and i said my next
question was
are you will you apologize i want to
issue on behalf of the
nhs and the whole healthcare system i
want to issue a
full apology to the uh to the those
who've suffered
and their families for the for the
frustration
for the time that it's taken that
they've taken
to get the uh to get their voices heard
[Music]
i just thought of all the families i
thought of i thought of nikki
and i thought of the mothers i'd met who
lost their children
and i thought about is that word
avoidable isn't it
you know all of this could have been
avoided
and all that heartbreak
and all the struggle they've had in
their lives
and finally
someone had admitted it wasn't their
fault
they'd done nothing wrong and then i
thought of the fact that
they'd had to make this happen that
through all the difficulties that they'd
had
they were the ones and only them
who got the authorities to open
their eyes and see what had happened
[Music]
we don't stop fighting now this is the
moment where we step up
we've got to keep that momentum going so
um if people think we've
been shut up they'll be very um sadly
mistaken
i'm extremely protective of my family
there is absolutely no way i will give
up on this
until we have complete justice
they have this one final hurdle
this huge pharmaceutical company to take
on
that's their last big battle
bayer would be stupid to underestimate
mary lyon
you know they might think they're
massive
but she is not going to give up
my money's on her
back in july the cumberland review team
said that bayer had a moral
and ethical duty to make amends to the
victims of primitives
now we've approached the company's chief
executive for an interview and he's been
unavailable so we've come here to their
headquarters
in leverkusen in germany to see if he'll
speak to us
mr spellman from sky news are you going
to compensate the victims of primitives
is bear going to pay them compensation
[Music]
the way that we've been treated by bayer
is basically with contempt
we have been forced to battle we've been
forced to wait
i'm extremely optimistic that we have a
case to answer
this fight stops when we win and not
[Music]
before
[Music]
you